c'est le pdc quoi vous avez déjà
sûrement vous de vraiment de moments de
solitude votre pire moment de solitude
week-end alors moi c'est les mecs qui se
mouche alors je sais que c'est bien de
se moucher c'est enfin faut se mouiller
dans la vie mais on n'est vraiment pas
obligé de sortir son ancien mouchoir de
la whl les quartiers comme ça romain va
pas utiliser ce mot chier devant la
mairie
mais vous êtes sorti qu'un mec de 61 ans
nadia des jeux sur wii à voilà moi
j'avais eu un truc et on a un truc de
solitude faut se tourner vers ithaque en
salle et on n'a pas vu un truc pire que
ça avoir vraiment besoin de pression
quand le mec est en train de t'embrasser
du ligue ndi qui va se rendre mais toi
ce que tu dis sur le sur le fait de se
moucher moi j'ai eu pire j'ai vu un mec
qui avait la nappe et c'est un patron à
niamey ont déjeuné ensemble il y avait
une nappe hypra l'anah il se mouiller
ouais c'est un patron de donc j'ai passé
le déjeuner les jambes écartées mais pas
pour le bon motif
qu'elle est belle elle est bien à quoi
nathalie s'est impatienté moment de
solitude ça tu connais aussi
oui mais c'était un premier rendez vous
amoureux justement j'aime avec jean
pierre pernaut
non ce n'était pas avec lui c'était
juste avant lui a fait perdre sous
tutelle face aux pertes non les mais
alors si vous nous rejoignez amateur
saint-quentin discours oui nathalie
matte est sorti et sert qu'aux de la
bouffe on n'en finira donc tout le monde
le kif et ben ouais ça c'est pas pire
qu'aux électeurs comment qu'aux modo
m'était très bien je regarde alors avec
tout le monde ça alors ouais alors on va
dire à coutrai et donc il m'invite au
resto etc
et à un moment j'ai une des couronnes au
bout en qui c'est qui ce qui n'en fait
pas sauter quelques années on était en
train de manger chez eux et je fais je
fais quoi et donc j'ai dû la sortir
discrètement elle à cacher faisait plus
rire aux éclats
c'était évident c'est avec percussions
un an puis d'un an et fort la la j'aime
bien ce douteux